- [Narrator] In France,
pastry reigns supreme.
From the kouign-amann,
to the pain au chocolat,
it's all here.
- (in foreign language)
(laughs)
- Wait what is happening here?
(cheerful music)
So, it turns out that the
name of this pastry has
been at the center of a debate in France
for quite some time now.
The question at hand:
"What do you call this?"
- (in foreign language)
- There seem to be two camps.
Those that call this:
- (in foreign language)
- And those that call it:
- And according to this map,
it's clear where the
lines have been drawn.
So, here we are, in
France, not to pick a side,
but to hear from both camps.
We begin in Paris, with
the pain au chocolat.
- (in foreign language)
(in foreign language)
- And now, we head South, to Toulouse,
for camp chocolatine.
- (in foreign language)
(in foreign language)
- Well, we checked on the
origin of these terms,
and both are hazy.
But, from chefs, to the everyday citizen,
there are opinions, memes,
and trending hashtags galore.
This debate actually reached
the French parliament,
where members were fighting
to have chocolatine
officially recognized.
- (in foreign language)
(in foreign language)
- Even President Macron
has spoken about it.
- (in foreign language)
(in foreign language)
(bright music)
- (in foreign language)
(in foreign language)